my mother would always say habla hablane
and my grandmother would add avla fuerte
[Music]
you're told a story your dreams go to a
certain level but no
my dreams can reach any level we're not
the stories that people have told about
us but we're the stories that i might
tell or that my children might tell
i believe that we are the new mainstream
and there is so much more that we can do
that we can learn from
most people when they meet me they don't
realize that i'm latino and i remember
thinking wow
okay i'm different my name is olga
meredith
or olga meredith depending i get this
opportunity to come to broadway i had no
idea of the magnitude of what was
happening
i cannot speak to all of our experiences
but i will show up for my community any
chance i get back in the day it was like
you're a boy why are you wearing makeup
now it was like hey what eyeliner are
you using i'm not saying you have to
accept it because it's latin
i'm saying you shouldn't reject it
because it's flat every community should
have a seat at the table and latch on to
each other because there's strength in
numbers habla habla habla loud
you